one of the attacks that the living
constitutionalist have waged against
this revival of original understanding
of the Constitution is that we never can
understand your true intent of the
founders I am always skeptical that we
can know what was the original intent
behind a constitutional provision
well that's not what originalism is it's
not what their subjective unspoken
intent was it's what they conveyed by
the words they use to the people who
would then subsequently vote to ratify
the Constitution or the amendments it's
also skeptical that even if we knew it
should be binding on us today if the
words no longer mean anything then we
don't have a constitution that binds and
limits the power of government and
government can do whatever would they
want the Commerce Clause it's 16 words
and two commas they're not even hard
words most people can figure out what it
means
sadly Congress is not most people I'm
assuming to be in the Commerce Clause
without Congress legislates all kinds of
programs they can't wink indeed the
federal government yes can do most
anything in this country I don't worry
about the Constitution on this to be
honest my mom that's not - jackpot
brother what was originally intended to
be a restriction on States has been
rewritten into a grant of virtually
unlimited power to Congress how did we
get here what is meant by the term
Commerce the world is so different now
for what it was in 1787 but I think that
what the framers intended with the
commerce clause was if Congress broad
authority to regulate all aspects of the
economy really all aspects of the
economy Commerce at the time of the
founding meant trade you had
manufacturing that was not Commerce you
had a Greek altar that was not commerce
you had retail sales that was not
commerce the issue involves the economic
welfare of the United
but it also involves the balance of
power between the federal government and
the government of the states regulating
commerce among the states meant
regulating the trade so a state couldn't
impose trade barriers which often worth
a precursor to war the Commerce Clause
was created to quash the commercial
warfare that threatened to break the
states apart and for over 100 years
Congress exercised the commerce power
only in that way preventing interference
with interstate commerce but the Great
Depression the New Deal in FDR's court
packing plan put substantial pressure on
the courts to accept dramatically
expanded federal powers to justify new
laws the court seized on a few lines
from an 18 24 48 known as Gibbon versus
Ogden Marshall wrote a fairly narrow
opinion well because his formulation
said that Commerce which does not have a
substantial effect on other states they
picked up on that rhetoric and the
Supreme Court has very broadly defined
the scope of Congress commerce power and
now said well anything that does have a
substantial effect on Commerce any
activity that affects more than one
state can be regulated by Congress which
was not Marshalls intent at all well are
you leading this mr. Marshall and then
all of a sudden you get Wickard versus
filburn which is probably the broadest
most expansive interpretation ever given
of the Commerce Clause Roscoe filburn
grew wheat on his farm for his own home
consumption his entire crop was fed to
his livestock consumed by his family or
stored for planting in the next year the
wheat was never bought never sold and
never left the state so he was
deliberately not engaging in interstate
commerce and yet the Supreme Court ruled
that his crop could be regulated under
the authority of the interstate commerce
clause because if everyone grew their
own wheat no one would buy any their
failure to engage in commerce would have
a substantial effect on Commerce and
therefore Congress could regulate it
Congress can regulate any activity the
taking cumulatively has a substantial
effect interstate commerce of course
that turns the Commerce Clause upside
down and it's no longer a power to
regulate interstate commerce it's a
power to regulate everything
Wickard is wrongly decided and it needs
to be overturned in the wake of the New
Deal the Commerce Clause continued to
expand into all aspects of American life
from 1937 to 1995 not a single piece of
legislation was struck down as exceeding
the scope of Congress's Commerce Clause
Authority and then the court decided
United States versus Lopez the issue at
hand was the gun-free school zones Act
the statute prohibited possession of a
gun within a hundred yards of a school
and nobody supports possession of a gun
within 100 yards of school Texas had a
law against that in fact the question is
whether it was in the federal
government's authority for the majority
the relationship to interstate commerce
was too attenuated there was no
interstate commerce connection to that
statute and they struck it down they
don't explicitly overrule Wickard versus
filburn
even though the reasoning of the case
cannot be squared with Wickard versus
filburn
the opportunity confronts them to
address that in the medical marijuana
case out of California
angel race grew and consumed of medical
marijuana in her home which was legal
under California's Compassionate Use Act
but illegal under federal law it's like
the homegrown weed case this should have
been a judgment left to California the
court said producing a crop that's
bought and sold interstate commerce
albeit illegally for marihuana is
economic activity that reaffirms Wickard
versus filburn
and largely repudiates the Commerce
Clause revolution above Lopez so just
how powerful is the Commerce Clause we
may find out soon a number of states
have challenged the Obamacare the
nationalized health care bill that came
out this past year and the first
challenge is on Commerce Clause grounds
the question revolves around the
individual mandate that's why under my
plan individuals will be required to
carry basic health feature Congress can
force economic transactions in the 1964
Civil Rights Act the court said hotels
and restaurants can be forced under
Congress commerce power to serve or rent
to African Americans even if they don't
want to requiring people of health
insurance meets the rational basis test
just like every Court has said it means
rational-basis review to require that
all drivers have car insurance everybody
in America just about has to get auto
insurance well there's a huge difference
the act of driving is not a
constitutional right it's a privilege
and so we can impose conditions on the
exercise of that privilege under the
state's police power living is not a
privilege but it's a right and I can't
impose a condition on the mere act of
living which is what the Obamacare
mandate does if you don't follow the
mandate and by the insurance policy that
the government orders you to buy then
you get taxed I call this a penalty
government is going through contortions
trying to say it's it's not a tax nobody
considers that a tax increased well if
it's not a tax they don't have authority
to do it so they have to say it is a tax
one reason that the government want to
call it a tax a purpose of litigation is
it's clear that you can't argue that it
tax is an unconstitutional taking a
private property without just
compensation but if it is a tax it does
two things it violates President Obama's
pledge that he wouldn't raise taxes you
can't just make up that language and
decide that that's called tax increase
and it's a tax not tied to income that
means it's a direct tax and the
Constitution is very clear direct taxes
have to be apportioned according to
population well this would be
apportioned according to whether you
bought the policy or not not according
to population and it's invalid under
article 1 of the Constitution I think
the Supreme Court will uphold this I
think it may never go to the Supreme
Court if my prediction is right the
courts of appeals will uphold this is
constitutional the Supreme Court is
going to have to take it it's too big a
deal for an intermediate appellate court
to have the final say on it so where is
the limit of congressional power under
the Commerce Clause the limit is the
extent of the creativity of the members
of Congress if I wanted to sponsor a
bill and it said Americans you have to
eat three vegetables and three fruits
every day does that violate the Commerce
Clause
sounds like a dumb law do we have the
power to tell people what they have to
eat every day then her view of the
Constitution there's nothing that
Congress can't do what she said was oh
that would never happen that's a foolish
law she never said it would be
unconstitutional I think what people
choose to eat well might be regarded as
a personal liberty the government can
force you to eat three meals a day eat
McDonald's hamburgers not eat McDonald's
hamburgers what we put into our bodies
really is part of our freedom but it's
not a freedom to not have medical care
by General Motors cars instead of Toyota
cars in theory Congress could use its
commerce power required people buy cars
in reality it's a ridiculous
hypothetical all sorts of things that
the government now compelled you to do
if the individual mandate is upheld
power can be used in silly ways and the
Constitution isn't our protector against
undesirable government actions only
unconstitutional and ultimately the
fight over the scope of the Commerce
Clause is about that do we have a
government that is limited in purpose
and in its powers to do only the things
that we the sovereign people gave it to
do for certain designated purposes or is
it an amorphous unlimited government
that can do to us whatever it wants
why have we got a republic or a monarchy
a republic if you can keep it so
[Music]